[Musique]
le piano du café de la grave ce fait
accorder ce signe que la saison
touristique madelinienne peut commencer
ce soir c'est un peu spécial parce que
cela va bien sûr lesquels de musique qui
cette année au café de la même si le son
du piano sera juste la saison
touristique
elle sera dissonante melli malines on
refuse de céder à la panique
ben c'est certain qu'on s'attend quand
même à une grosse baisse le parce que
les derniers était arrêté quand même
cédé été record je pense pour tout le
monde
il y avait beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
touristes mais ont ils vont eva la
semaine où on va être content les gens
qui vont avoir fait tout le chemin pour
venir vont être contents d'être là oui
bon le vent nouveau
c'est ce qui est fort notamment parlé
c'est pas la même à craindre de nous ici
ça faisait la fête bat homme d'état on
avait cinquante huit classes dont on m'a
32 à quelques pas de là on s'affaire à
préparer la boutique de bijoux
l'optimisme est au rendez vous car si
les touristes sont moins nombreux à
venir dans l'archipel en raison de la
coved 19
les madelinots sont également moins
enclins à en sortir pour leurs propres
vacances peut-être les à chocques
auraient été faits au nouveau brunswick
au ou à montréal à québec seront en fait
sur la grappe
une chose est sûre lakovic 9 n'aura pas
entacher la beauté des paysages
madelinots arrivé depuis quelques heures
aux îles de la madeleine
cette famille de trois rivières a déjà
oublié la traversée pénible des
provinces maritimes avec les palais et
la mer la conduite de nuit est posée par
le nouveau-brunswick et
l'île-du-prince-édouard semble déjà bien
loin
non ça valait vraiment la peine mais
franchement
puis je leur ai pleuré je leur ferai le
demain pour revenir le même si ce raid
ou trois jours ici ça vaut la firme avec
ou sans pandémie les touristes demeure
sous le charme
ne reste plus qu'à espérer en it et sans
fausse note
ici j'avais la rose radio canada aux
îles de la madeleine
[Musique]